I think we were all surprised of course
and ultimately saddened we forged ahead
and we were so thankful that you were
able to complete the series as planned
robin wright opening up about the
aftermath of Kevin Spacey's sexual
assault scandal on The Today Show the
pair co-starred on Netflix is house of
cards for five seasons the streaming
service fired Spacey after several
sexual misconduct allegations surfaced
against the actor was there any kind of
red flag or anything that would've made
you think this was possible Kevin and I
knew each other between action and cut
and in between setups where we would
giggle I didn't really I didn't know the
man I knew the incredible craftsman that
he is Spacey who played President Frank
Underwood on the political drama has
denied all wrongdoing and right says she
hasn't been in contact with the actor I
haven't heard from him and I don't even
know how to reach him do you feel like
Netflix did the right thing in cutting
ties I don't know how to comment on that
but I think at that time the shock was
so intense all over the nation for many
reasons many stories many people I think
that everybody felt that it was
respectful to back off right well Speer
had the show's sixth and final season
set to premiere this fall we're just
getting started
something in co-star Patricia Clarkson
said Wright fought to make happen
Robin led all of this this charge so
that people would save their livelihood
because when the show goes away some
people don't get paid and they it's I
think it's gonna be a stunning stunning
new season
[Applause]
[Music]